اذا المشاهدين يشكل الحاله الثوري
الايراني اليد العسكريه والسياسيه للمرشد
الاعلى علي خمنائي المثيره للقلق وفق
تقرير نشارته مجالات التايمل الامريكيه
الحرس الثوري الايراني تاسس عام
وادرجته واشنطن على قائمه الارهاب عام
2017 يمتلك هذا الكيان قوات بحريه وفضائيه
واستخباراتيه ولديها ايضا ترسانه صاروخيه
كبيره وترسانه من الطائرات من دون طيار
مصنوعه محليا ايضا تحت مسمى فيلق القدس
يشارك نحو مئتي الف مسلح من خارج ايران
اين هم موزعين على دول العراق لبنان سوريا
واليمن ودائما وفقا لتقرير نشره موقع قوات
مشاه البحريه الامريكيه الان العد
المحتمله لعناصر الحرس قد يصل الى ثمانيه
ملايين من رجال ونساء او حتى نحو 10% من
سكان ايران تقول تايم ويشكك فيها محللون
عسكريون غربيون لكن القوه العسكريه
الفعليه للحرس هي اقل من ذلك بكثير كما
يبدو حيث يشير تقرير المعهد الامريكي
للسلام نشر عام 2010 الى ان عدد قوات
الحرس يصل الان الى 150,000 رجل مقسمين
بين قوات بريه بحريه وايضا جويه التقرير
نقل عن القائد في الحرس الثوري اللواء
جعفر قوله ان ما يقرب من
200,000 شاب من جميع انحاء الشرق الاوسط
تم تنظيمهم وتسليحهم تحت قياده في نقل
القدس اما المجله الامريكيه كشفت ايضا ان
عناصر الحرس هم
طاحونه مغسول ادمغه الجيولوجيه ويمكن
تعبئتهم بسهوله وغالبا ما يتم توظيفهم في
السفارات والجمعيات وايضا المؤسسات
الدينيه وثقافيه
[موسيقى]